the idea of why being Moody could be
good for you really has to do with
taking advantage of one of the biggest
strengths and assets that women have
which is intuition knowing that
something is wrong feeling that
something is wrong and then optimally
speaking up about it
the first thing to keep in mind I think
that's very important is that a mood
disorder which is a sort of a
psychiatric diagnosis it's not what
we're talking about what I'm talking
about is an emotion that comes over you
and lasts maybe 15 to 90 seconds and
then if you really feel it and allow it
to pass it will moods can change minute
to minute and someone who is moody
exhibits a lot of different moods and
what we're talking about really is the
expression of emotion feeling and
emotion sitting with it really
understanding it and then conveying it
to somebody else this is how I feel so
for example say in the days leading up
to your period where you may feel that
you're more sensitive to your
environment or that you have a thinner
skin or your cry more easily you're more
sensitive to rejection it's actually
good to pay attention to these sort of
things because the truth is the rest of
the month you're sort of sealing that
over you're repressing it you're
stifling it you're covering it over but
those things are actually important and
what you're feeling
for instance perhaps you're dissatisfied
with somebody or a relationship or
something in your life but the rest of
the month you know you're pretty easy
breezy and accommodating but then those
few days before your period where you do
start to be more discerning and critical
it's important to pay attention to that
sort of thing if we feel our emotions
and are able to express you know what
you're doing is upsetting to me I think
what you're doing is wrong everybody
benefits and hopefully behaviors improve
one of my concerns that I write about a
moody bitch is is that I'm worried that
because so many people now are choosing
to take psychiatric medications and
antidepressants anti-anxiety meds but
they're tamping down how they feel and
you know when sometimes intuition is
about having an uneasy feeling you know
something is wrong and I'm a little bit
anxious and you know if you stop and
think about how you're feeling and you
pay attention to whether you get anxious
or not you can really take advantage of
that the
further away we get from nature and from
what is natural for us as social
primates the more sick and miserable
we're going to be I'm seeing this in my
private practice in psychiatry for
decades now that if someone is sort of
truer to themselves and how they feel
and how they are and also doing things
that are more natural for us like moving
your body being outside getting some Sun
you know there are very real
consequences to moving away from nature
and what's natural for us